why can we access array properties
what's so special about arrays arrays
are actually special kinds of objects in
JavaScript in fact this is a nice
transition let's get into objects food
dude oh dude my hands are like handy yes
they are and while you're staring at
your hands I'm going to be a
professional okay what I mean is angelic
objects because they can hold
information and do things true that is
an analogy objects in JavaScript can be
declared and defined in a few different
ways and all of them are different than
the way Python defines classes and
objects because there are no classes in
JavaScript let's repeat that javascript
doesn't include classes just objects
there are ways to mimic classes in some
respects but they are still just objects
right and this has some pretty
interesting implications check out the
instructor notes for more information
let's start defining objects with object
literal notation an object literal
notation will use the same var syntax as
we have before then we'll give the
object a name then an equal sign and
then the object is going to be defined
within these curly braces these curly
braces indicate that you're using object
literal notation let's define an object
from my biography then inside the curly
braces we can define the object's
properties using key value pairs I'll
create a property called name and save
my name as the value I'll do the same
for H this time using the number 32 my
age notice that we surrounded the
properties with quotation marks because
they're strings and there's a comma
between the two key value pairs ah
thanks but we can save whatever we want
here we could even save an array in our
object for instance I want to add skills
to my biography so let's take Cameron
skills from up here and add it to my
biography down here is that because
you're jealous
okay maybe this is pretty
straightforward to access these
properties later just as we did with the
array length we simply add property
after the object name so if I wanted to
append James's name to the page all I
need to do is access the bio name
property to pull James's name out of his
bio object then I'll go ahead and append
it to the page
come over here hit refresh we can see
that we've got James on our page now
nice let's give our students a shot